hi uh this is Mark uh CEO and founder of
tungle this one's going to be short uh
we made a cool release uh last weekend
and I wanted to talk to you about one
specific thing that we released which is
our tangle me widget uh if you remember
of course most of you have a page like
this with your Tango me page that allows
anybody that goes to your URL for
example mine is toggle
me.markle me slash mark
to schedule meetings with me now what
we've done is we've we've allowed you to
take this page and bring it wherever you
want through our Tango me widget so
think of it like a mini version of your
Tango me page if you go and you can
embed this little JavaScript that we've
got and I'm going to show you where to
get it it basically puts an icon like
this wherever you want on your web page
your blog your social network and so on
and what you do is you click on it and
it gives you a mini version of your
Tango me page you can even see you know
the different information that you've
put links to your Twitter feed LinkedIn
profile and so on as well as your
different availability
right so uh this is what it does uh so
now people from your blog or web page
can schedule a meeting with you without
having to register to tungle uh and I
can start by proposing multiple times
for the meeting like they could on your
tungle me page uh so pretty cool stuff
um to get it you basically log into your
tongle account you go to the management
Tab and you'll see there in the extras a
link for the widget that basically
describes how to put it on your page so
check it out
um we're really
excited about this capability so uh try
it out let us know how it works alright
keep on going